I am planning a traveling over Christmas to Puerto Rico. Hey, you know, if you are going to go to
Puerto Rico, you really need to bring me with just to check out, you know, the place. It sounds like
a wonderful retreat. I have never traveled via airlines with my right. Any tips on travel. I have
reluctant to check my right as baggage for fear of damage, even though the travel case is fairly robust.
So what I have traveled with my right a lot, any time I went out of seminar, any time I, you know,
went anywhere I always brought my right with. And I'll be honest, I don't have a hard case.
So I never brought it with a hard case. I think you don't have to worry at all if you're going to
bring your hard case. My only fear in, I just wrapped it in a sweatshirt in my suitcase. My only
fear was what if they lose my suitcase. It really wasn't a fear that it was going to get damaged.
I wrapped it in a sweatshirt and wrapped that in another shirt. So I didn't feel like it was going
to get shook around too much. I feared that they were going to lose my suitcase. So that I started
to just put it in my carry on. If you're going to bring your carry on as the plastic case that the
right came in, then you have to worry about it at all. Going through the TSA though, they will ask you
what it is. You could say it's a right machine. It's a light frequency machine. It's going to go through
X, right? They're going to see it's not a bomb. They're going to look at you weird. But you know, I've
gotten, every time I bring it as a carry on, they, I get pulled over. So plan on a few extra
minutes because they're going to pull your bag off and you're going to have to, you know, they're going
to look through it and do a swab test to make sure there's no bomb substance or something.
Then they're going to ask you, you know, I've had people not ask me what it is at all. They just
said it, you know, just sometimes they're not very friendly. The last time I went, they said,
what is this? I said, it's a right machine. It's a light therapy machine. And he, he like,
whatever. I'm sure they get tons of stuff. They think that people are just weird.
You know, sure, they thought that of me. So I wouldn't be worried about it. My only concern,
traveling with the right is what if they lose my bag. Now, all the years I've traveled, I've never
had a bag lost my wife did, but we did get her bag the next day. But I've heard of people that didn't
have their bag for the whole vacation, you know, so then you don't have your right for the whole
vacation. That would be my concern. So.